today we have a proposal from Bernie
Sanders that is an area where he really
stands out in the Democratic field it's
his plan to get money out of politics
now let's set up the conversation we've
been having a practical discussion here
on this show for a while now about
Bernie versus Warren on accepting
corporate and PAC money now both Bernie
and Warren have turned it down in
primaries Elizabeth Warren has said she
would accept it in the general election
saying she doesn't believe in unilateral
disarmament and if this is the way to
win she thinks we were better off with
her accepting that money and winning
rather than turning it down and losing
and seeing Donald Trump re-elected
Bernie has said he would not accept that
money in the general election and this
has become a sort of battleground on the
issue of campaign finance reform now I
want money out of politics period I
don't have to qualify it in any other
way money in politics is a toxic and
corrosive force it needs to be done away
with it needs to be removed it needs to
be reformed and I do believe that it is
a conversation to have about whether by
unilaterally disarming in the general
election you risk losing the election
and whether it is short-sighted in the
sense that by getting into office if you
accept that money in the general you
might then be able to change the system
now this is a theoretical conversation
I'm not looking to fight anyone over it
there are reasonable positions to be had
on both sides but I still think that if
you win you have to work to get rid of
campaign of money in politics and to
change and fix campaign financing I
don't know that Elizabeth Warren would
do that but this is a very specific
conversation to this election about
primarily two candidates of the three
frontrunners Biden certainly not going
to do anything about this the right
thing to do is we need money out of
politics and Bernie Sanders has put out
an absolutely fantastic plan to do it
Bernie's plan is all-encompassing in
that it would restructure money in
politics when it comes to parties and
conventions and inaugurations which by
the way inaugurations for Donald Trump
have served as a great way to funnel
money for influence peddling
for buying influence it would
restructure public financing of
Elections primary debate funding
Congress everything so let's look at the
details
number one Bernie would end corporate
contributions to the Democratic
convention period this is already just a
great way to set the tone before you
even formally nominate someone this is
absolutely a great thing to be doing
Bernie would end corporate donations to
the DNC period and to inaugurations and
individual donations to inaugurations
would be capped at $500 excellent Bernie
would make federal elections publicly
funded this is like the big boy right
this is the real hallmark of any serious
plan to get money out of politics and to
fix the problems that we have Bernie
would get rid of the Federal Elections
Commission and instead would replace it
with a federal election administration
with a governing body of its own
Bernie also wants a constitutional
amendment to overturn citizens united
that's not unique to Bernie Bernie wants
to end super PACs by legislation and
this is a very interesting component of
the plan Bernie would install a
universal small dollar voucher system
which would quote give any voting age
American the ability to donate to
federal candidates this is empowering
people in a way that not only are you
democratizing the financing of elections
you were also hopefully by getting
people involved in supporting candidates
with money they wouldn't ordinarily even
necessarily have to donate you're making
it more likely they're actually going to
participate in the system by voting
which is a major problem in this country
Bernie would ban advertising during
primary debates and he would put in
place a lifelong lobbying ban on former
members of Congress actually doing the
thing that Donald Trump claimed he would
do but hasn't actually done these are
the big elements it's not all
encompassing there are a few more so
here's the reality I always want to just
talk about the reality with you and not
dance around what it is that's going on
in polling Elizabeth Warren is surging
she has overtaken Joe Biden in a number
of recent polls and she may soon
overtake the lead in the 2020 Democratic
primary Bernie and Warren are sort of
fighting for the progressive vote either
would be the most progressive president
that we have ever had but we can't
ignore that on this issue Bernie is
unparalleled
in the Democratic primary period there's
no need to qualify it further every time
I say something objective about Bernie
or Warren people email me David I'm
disappointed I'm gonna not watch anymore
because you know I'm a bernie guy and
you're really going to Warren or I'm not
gonna watch anymore because I'm for
Warren and now you're just propping up
Bernie you're a Bernie bro David or I'm
angry because you're you know hurt
trying to hurt Bernie or attacking
Warren or whatever I am communicating
the facts Warren is surging in the polls
bernie is unparalleled on this issue of
money in politics and this plan is an
extraordinarily strong framework and to
quote Donald Trump I hope that whoever
is the next president looks at this very
very strongly because it is one of the
foremost issues if we want to really fix
politics this has to be at the top of
the list along with of course climate
change and dealing with systemic and
structural wealth and income inequality
in this country we are doing something
very exciting over the weekend we've
haven't done this for like a year we are
going to be having a one-day membership
fund drive blowing out memberships at a
historic discount if you have been
thinking about getting a membership to
the David Pakman show which is our
number one funding source of course get
on our mailing list by signing up for
the newsletter at david pakman.com this
weekend you will get an email the
subject will probably be I don't know
that I haven't written it yet that email
you've been waiting for and it will
contain a one-day coupon code to get the
biggest membership discount of the year
we've got a boost membership we are
ramping up for the 2020 election we want
to be doing a lot of new things once I'm
fully recovered from my emergency
appendectomy of course
and membership is the way that we fund
all of that so get on the mailing list
at david pakman.com major discount
coming up this weekend and of course
follow me on twitter at D Pakman and
follow the show on Twitter at David
Pakman show I want to tell you about one
of our sponsors called the Menlo Club
immense fashion community that provides
carefully curated style packages for any
type of guy and they're giving you as a
David Pakman show viewer your first box
for $35 off when you click the link
underneath this video or go to their
site and use the promo code Pakman as a
member of the Menlo Club you receive
delivered right to your door a
hand-picked apparel package that follows
the seasons latest trends based on your
own unique style profile I hate shopping
for clothes it's always been a pain to
go to a store figure out what to buy and
that's why the Menlo Club is so perfect
for me all I had to do was fill out a
quiz on their website so they could
learn my sizes and style preferences and
then I received clothes that perfectly
fit my own personal style so far I've
really enjoyed what they've sent me all
of their clothing is designed by their
team in Los Angeles
each box features items from their own
in-house fashion brands 5 for everyday
wear New Republic Footwear and Grande
see athleisure wear in every box they
send you you get a minimum of two items
often more every box is different
shipping is always free and they let you
exchange what you get if it doesn't fit
you can pause or cancel your
subscription at any time right now I am
on their monthly subscription for 60
bucks a month but they also offer a
seasonal subscription where they send
you a box of clothing every three months
for just 75 bucks but regardless of
which option you choose they are giving
everyone in our audience $35 off their
first box to redeem your $35 discount
just click the link under this video or
go to their website and use the promo
code Pakman at checkout